here's a reminder again he's still
just 22 years old Paul marray over
the line lost it in the skates of
Andrew Peak gave it away to dopson
look at that pass and they score doson
to egg ball and an early one for the
Islanders I guess that's the key to scoring goals
is just talk about a player how wonderful he's
been playing and that that's the key the
Islanders start to head down the pass goes
a little bit astray but look at Dobson he's up
on the play gets gets his feet moving and then
a beautiful pass Ang ball says I can handle that
one there but look at darra all the way looking
knows there's nothing at the net so let me see if
there's another option and that goes off the waist
four goals now on the year three of them have come
in the last four games here's barzel picking it up
he's got Horvat 2 barzel back head save Martin
he's in the net where's the puck I think that's
in guys I don't know I have been corrected Butch
four time Stanley Cup champion Billy Caroll he
won one with Edmonton too here's Grover off to the
backand and a save by barov but a penalty called
on the play good acceleration on the other side
you know we stopped skating there the back Checker
trying to look at that b hor big challenge for
the uh for the Islanders they're trying to set a
record tonight you like kings are look out here in
Montreal here's a chance for Jenner on a breakaway
Sav by barl important Faceoff win but then doson
couldn't clear it it was kept Alive by blankenberg
doson and Raman Al will try the near side now
this time it gets out not deep not yet as weny
has it pinned right in front of the scorers table
it's Johnson into the zone for Fant Tilly fanly
as he's falling and they score it took a hop off
the back boards right to bemstrom and the Columbus
Blue Jackets have tied it that's for manov as
he gets beat to the inside now he's chasing it
isers are coming back and that's just a a tough
break for the Islanders golender our La off as
he's big F two at his bounc and hrom doesn't get
back in time a similar situation Butch I talked
about that dot line Mayfield over for Riley with
a PA and a shot and a save from Martin another
big rebound Brendon that's we talk about shots
of the point someone should stay a little higher
pass here's Johnson got it across and they score
Adam fan Tilly on a broken play gives the Blue
Jackets the 2-1 lead that was an oddb Rush after
the Islanders went down had an opportunity not
able to get back out of their Zone the ERS have
an opportunity Riley there's the big rebound and
now look at the ERS are all trapped it's a four on
on three basically nice passing play by everybody
Johnson and good he faked the shot lost the puck
a little bit there didn't he and then he gets it
over to fany lensky gets it back watch Johnson
he fanned on it I think or did he fake it I
don't know I think he fan and it worked out broken
stick for fanelli on the pl and bean will elevate
it into the neutral zone cikas delays with that
puck fashing Clutterbuck alone in front and he
scores Cal Clutterbuck with a big goal
to tie just curves him down the middle
a little mistake by the Columbus Blue Jackets
the turnover with quick transition and take a
little look a little chip pass and fasy makes
the great play and clutter beats the go tender
on the sticks low on the stick side so huge goal
for the Islanders as they were getting totally
outplayed spent as you mentioned a long long
time but clutter doesn't panic he gets it on
his backand here's barzel with a minute 20 on
the clock trying to weave his way through the
blue jacket defense winds its way around for Riley
open ice for Mayfield his slap pass Ricochet bzel
scores Matt bzel had to get rid of it in a hurry
and the Islanders late in the second have retaken
the lead and Martin didn't see that puck as rensky
was standing right in front of him the lucky one
is barzel trying to get in a little stick handling
here and there good support by Horvat but watch
this Puck as bar is going to stay out to the wide
side number eight watch him he's going to end up
screening his goal tender and barzel makes no
mistake Riley all the way across to Mayfield
and good deflection there for the Islanders that
wasn't a pass half of it scheduled here for the
second the other half for the start of the third
Islanders trying to add to the lead Islanders
power play was two for three on Tuesday night
against San Jose barzel Nelson score Kyle pal
Mar a tap in set up by Brock Nelson a beautiful
power play goal that that all starts with good
hard work along the board for the Islanders with
pal Mar and Blue Jackets try to put pressure on
the Islanders here's the original okay there's
the scamble Islanders stay right with it horvat's
able to get it back and here goes the round the
horn but watch the pressure Force the man as best
you can there's the pass and pulled him out of
position that right defenseman's got no chance
to get back the man alive is not a good play
and PS I told you he from a score tonight yeah
and Riley took bstrm out of the play with the puck
comes to Johnson thrown to the front Riley and
bemstrom are still battling and fantelli keeps
it shot it hit off barzel comes to Jake bean
bean slips down the boards barzel made the play
defensively but it popped in front for fantelli
and he scores just a minute and 28 seconds in a
two goal night for Adam Fant Tilly and a one-goal
game here in the third period that looked like
just a bad bounce for for for the Islanders but
you know the Islanders now everybody's back and
it's just a matter eliminating your men so how
does fan Tilly get all alone in front of the net
how does that happen and over on your left hand
side take a little look there that's Brock
Nelson and Rock's waiting and Thomson with a
shot right on and they score Matt barzel has
put the Islanders back up by two and there's
what you need from the Islanders you know a good
push we talked about in the last two three shifts
starts with a faceof win and good awareness of
where everybody is and Horvat With a Little Help
from Barelle shot from doson it's blocked from
watch this play as beautiful pass by horat he
knows he knows Bar's there good Puck retrieval
by the outter so a little hunger a little more
aggressiveness and that's the Columbus Blue Jacket
player and trying to see his number he shuffled
it away right to horback Holstrom right on him
Johnson stolen away by go chipped down the ice
warat he's fresh and he picks up the puck look
to the net and a save made got his own rebound
scores Bo horad with a Beauty Islanders
ahead by three and that was not an easy
goal to score I mean b coming off the bench
had really good speed watch b as he's coming
going to come off the bench little chip play
and there he goes right down the middle of the
ice has no angle he's below the dock but quick
rebound watch where he shoots that from I mean
that's about a foot off the uh maybe a foot
from the goal line that's really impressive
but you're right like there's no angle there
at all and do it on the back hand yeah that
I mean there's just wasn't a lot of room for
air but goal scorers are supposed to be able
to score those goals I guess well he's
done it for the eighth time this season
barzel thinking about wrapping it in front
they score Bo horback with two goals in 20
seconds well there's some happy fans now
Brendan Islanders have exploded in this
third period expect play in that third period and
barzel Horvat Horvat knows exactly what barzel is
going to do he's got the stick down on the ice
throws it out there no chance for for for the
goal tener didn't even look he did not look he
knew that Horvat was going to be going to the
net they gave up an early goal to let Columbus
get within one and then they responded in a big
way they score the final three goals of the
game pull away and beat the blue jacket 7 to3